- Eleanor Roosevelt
had an active
political career
in her own right.
She pushed the boundaries
of what it meant
to be a First Lady.
(upbeat music)
- Eleanor Roosevelt came from
a New York aristocratic family.
Her father was Teddy
Roosevelt's brother.
She meets Franklin Roosevelt.
They get married in 1905.
Franklin Roosevelt
is her fifth cousin.
She gave birth to six children.
In 1918, she discovers her
husband is having an affair
and that is when
childbearing and marital
intimacy come to an end.
- She lived a separate life.
He lived a separate life
but the relationship
with her husband
evolved where they were
well and truly partners.
- Eleanor Roosevelt
really innovated
the First Lady's role as
a public communicator.
- She wrote thousands
of columns, 27 books.
She participated in
hundreds of radio shows.
- When she came into
the White House,
one of the first things
she did was to establish
women-only press conferences.
So all the reporters
who covered her
who came to the White
House were female.
- She would give them tidbits
about White House life
that the male press
corps wasn't getting.
It saved a lot of
newspaper women's jobs.
- During World War II she
traveled to the front lines
in Europe and in the
Pacific to support soldiers.
- She met with
servicemen in hospitals,
took notes and even
contacted their families.
There were some
individuals that thought
that she should stay at
home and be the hostess
and nothing else.
That was not her.
- Eleanor Roosevelt's
biggest accomplishments
were the public
stances that she took,
especially about civil rights.
She went to Alabama
for a conference.
She requested a
chair of her own,
placed it squarely between
the aisle for whites
and the aisle for blacks.
It was a very visible
way to take a stand
in opposition to the Jim
Crow laws in the South.
- The work that she
did for equality
continued after she was
no longer First Lady.
- Harry Truman appointed
her as delegate
to the United Nations and she
was absolutely instrumental
in drafting the U.N.
Declaration of Human Rights,
which still informs human
rights around the world today.